قال الرئيس الفرنسي ايمانويل ماكرون انه
يرفض للجرار الى منافسه عفا عليها الزمن
بين من وصفها بالقوه المفترسه على موارد
القاره الافريقيه ولا يشعر بالحنين الى
فرنسا الافريقيه حيث كانت الروابط بين
فرنسا ومستعمراتها السابقه تشهد في بعض
الاحيان دعم باريس للانظمه الاستبداديه
وتحدث ماكرون في كلمه قبل جوله افريقيه
تبدا الاربعاء عن خيارات اخرى تسعى من
خلالها بلاده لبناء شراكه جديده مع الدول
الافريقيه
لتجنب تكرار التاريخ هناك خيارات اخرى
نتبعها على مدار السنوات الست الماضيه وهي
خيارات لا تقتصر على تحويل افريقيا فقط
الى مجاري للمنافسه والريع بل تعتبر
البلدان الافريقيه شركاء نتقاسم معها
المصالحه والمسؤوليات المشتركه وفي العمق
بناء علاقات جديده متوازنه
ومتبادله ومسؤوله
واضاف الرئيس الفرنسي ان القواعد العسكريه
الفرنسيه في افريقيا ستدار تدريجيا بشكل
مشترك مع الدول المستضيفه لها وقال ان هذا
التحول سيبدا في الاشهر المقبله وسيستند
الى مبدا التنميه المشتركه
بالنسبه الي هذه شروط الشراكه الجديده
التي نرغب فيها وهي النقيض لمنطق
الاستحواذ سواء كان عسكريا او امنيا او
ماليا الذي تدفع به بلدان اخرى
ولانجاح هذا النموذج من الشراكه نحتاج قبل
ذلك الى اقامه نموذج شراكه عسكريه والمنطق
هو ان نموذجنا لا ينبغي ان يكون قواعد
عسكريه كما هي موجوده حاليا غدا سيكون
وجودنا جزءا من نظام من المدارس
والاكاديميات التي ستدار بشكل مشترك
وسيعمل موظفون افارقه مع موظفين فرنسيين
سيبقون في تلك المواقع ولكن بمستويات اقل